[Music]
all right blade spits to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do i will deliver killing blows on this
for the six dummy randy you're up first
you ready i am let's do this
i don't know what to expect and i know
they gonna hit it hard
i'm a little bit jibbery
my legs want to give out from under me a
little bit but i think i'll be okay
nice
[Music]
all right let's talk about your sword of
mars here first up the damascus pattern
you have here is gorgeous
the weapon design is very aggressive for
thrusting and slashing now your handle
construction if you reverse this
it'll be easier to have something to
lock onto the fact that the flare is
right here forcing my hand to open up if
i want to marry into the hilt
this is a very sharp weapon the tip
pierces
all the way through cuts on the way out
it's pointy and scary and
it will kill right here good job all
right dan it is your turn you ready hell
yeah let's do this i was hoping the kill
test would be a dummy i know heads will
roll i'm feeling really confident i want
to see what this thing does
all right dance talk about your weapon
here i love the balance of your blade
when i go forward it's not hard to pull
back to go in again for another kill now
your handle construction it's curved
enough to where it doesn't want to fly
out of my hand it's got a good grip and
control for this your edge allows for
very deep cuts into the abdomen right
there the only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a bend when it's
chopped into the spine
but
your weapon sir will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry and through
his military campaigns he revolutionized
the use of horse in military conflicts
so to test the strength and durability
of your blades i'll be chopping into
these horse skulls
randy over first you ready i guess so
okay
i designed my blade with a sharp sharp
edge
and i'm a little worried my stomach's up
my throat a little bit
wow
okay so
right off the bat the biggest thing is
that this section from right about here
to here
has lost its edge
there's a couple of small rolls
blade's still straight it's all in one
piece still solid nicely done it's very
strong blade thank you all right dan are
you ready no but let's do it
everybody says that
the first test bent my blade
so i'm feeling a little bit of fear
going into the strength test this will
kill blades
it's a scary brutal thing
[Music]
at the guard
[Music]
okay so
before we get to the obvious i really
like the design of your blade it's got a
great weight to it had a really good
feel in my hand the balance was really
nice
see all that space around your tang
with that room for that blade to move
inside the guard it could just create so
much stress that it cut loose right
there at the corner if it were all tight
there would be any stress there's no
discoloration here so it's not that
there were there was a crack here before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but obvious flaw
dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test which means that we
can no longer test it
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand
and then please leave the forge
it hurts but my sword breaking it's
gonna be a reminder that i have to push
harder and be better man keep up the
work that's a good sort i came here to
prove that i can compete with the big
dogs and that i do know what i'm doing
and i think i might have accomplished
that
randy the strength and efficiency of
your weapon in the kill test have earned
you the title of forged and fire
champion and a check for how much
that's right ten thousand dollars good
job brother i won foraging fire it's
reality how do you feel good to be a
champion and be
recognized as a good smith is all real
good
this is my happy and excited face
hey if he didn't recognize it
[Music]
all right veterans welcome to the keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
weapon deliver killing blows to this big
carcass you're up first ready
[Laughter]
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
all right tyler your handle construction
just right
your edge
is very sharp
overall sir
this saber
will kill perfect
all right gene your turns are you ready
let's do this doug
all right genes this is a heavy sword
very forward heavy but when you have a
forward heavy blade that you're hitting
it meets resistance
a cylindrical
almost
circular handle
makes a twist in my hand so probably
this is the reason why the chain came
off
but your blade is sharp
it will heal
all right gentlemen december 25th 1776
george washington leads the continental
army across a frozen delaware river to
attack the hessians at trenton new
jersey and he probably didn't chip his
way through the ice but that's not going
to keep us from our strength test the
ice block chop
tyler you're up first are you ready uh
yeah yeah let's do it
all right so tyler your chain fell off
but there's no damage on your edge
your handle is comfortable other than
the chain you nailed it good job
all right gene
do it
all right gene your blade's edge
is still there and it's still sharp the
issue is
the rest of your chain fell off and it's
picked up a bend i have less issue with
that and more issue
with this polished handle it's just hard
to hold on to
but
it is strong
and it does have an edge so good job
all right veterans our sharpness test
today is the hessin charge
this is all about what your edge will do
to these dummies
tyler up first you ready for this yep
[Music]
[Music]
all right tyler the weight of your
weapon does prevent me from going very
fast but you have a very sharp edge all
the way through your weapon sir it will
cut thank you
all right gene it's your turn sir you
ready let's do this doug
[Music]
all right gene to be able to maintain
a good grip on this more of the cuts i
create are more impact as opposed to a
slash where it cuts all the way through
so you have some cuts here that are more
nicks
deep mix because you have a very sharp
edge
and for this test sir your weapon
will cut
awesome
tyler gene first of all i want to thank
you both for your service you're both
champions in my mind you've already won
your branch divisions but there can only
be one battle of the branches champion
and you'll walk out of here with a check
for 50 000
and that champion is
tyler congratulations you are the battle
of the branches forged and fire champion
gene
please surrender your blade
there's a lot of marines out there and
there's a lot of great guys in the
marine corps and so for me to stand here
and represent them is pretty humbling
i learned too that it's not about uh
just the melody forged in fire i feel
like i've been forged in fire and it's
how you handle the ups and downs the
wins the losses and it'll determine real
quick how you've been heat treated
throughout your life
tyler congratulations you overcame every
obstacle set in front of you you beat
out all the other smiths and now you're
the battle of the branches forest and
fire champion that's a title that comes
with a check for 50 000
and most importantly
bragging rights good job my brother
please present your blade to the judges
[Music]
i'm super excited when this whole thing
started i had no idea how it was all
gonna turn out feels good to
have represented the army the fact that
i just won fifty thousand dollars is
starting to set in
i'm sergeant tyler hackmart and i'm the
new battle of the branches champion
blade smith to test the lethality of
your cutlass i'm going to inflict lethal
wounds on these ballistic dummies
jason you are first you ready i sure
hope so doug let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right jason you got a very big
handle here but at least it's got the
swells it's got an indexing to where i
hold on to it i can tell where the edge
is
the weight that you have in this weapon
is so light and since that i can wield
it even around here you've got the
clavicle into the ribs all the way
through the lungs
and definitely it will kill
all i ever wanted to hear made my day
seth you're up next you ready get some
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right seth your sword is forward
heavy without a balance coming back i
don't know the shoulder is going to hurt
more the dummies are mine but your
weapon sir will kill
thank you
assess the strength and durability of
your swords i'll be chopping through
these bones and then attacking that peg
leg now remember this test is not about
what your blades do to these targets
it's about what these targets do to your
blades
jason you're up are you ready nope
[Music]
the balance of your weapon
is really nice which is surprising
because you've made a two-handed cutlass
your blade
held up very well except for the one
little chip and it's not even chipped to
roll
so it didn't blow out it's a good job
thank you dave
all right seth are you ready yes sir
all right seth
first up
this thing's a beast
it is probably a pound heavier than your
competitor's sword
your blade
i mean i can run my finger to inhale
down this i can see a couple of glinting
spots but it really didn't take any
damage
[Music]
all right bladesmiths let's find out if
there's any edge left this is the rope
cut and pirate sail slash to test the
edge of your cutlass i will cut this
rope which will raise the sail and then
i will slash the sail
this is all about what your sword will
do to the sailing rope
chasing you up first ready yes sir
[Music]
alrighty jason your edge cut through the
rope easily and cuts with every part
that the edge met on this pirate sail
overall sir your sword
will cut
awesome
seth how you feeling
feel good let's go let's do this
[Music]
all right seth
what are the chances you find a very
dull spot on the first cut on the rope
but on the second cut it found another
spot that was sharp but on the sail
working a heavy sword like this affects
my cuts
jason seth the judges have tested your
weapons and they've made a final
decision
our new forged and fire champion is
jason
congratulations you're the new forge and
fire champion
seth unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
seth your weapon was significantly
heavier and it had a stout edge that
underperformed on the sharpness test for
that reason we're sending you home
seth
please surrender your blade
no regrets man
i think i made an exceptional blade but
it is what it is you know elimination's
elimination that's the name of the game
i'm proud of myself but i don't feel as
good as i would have if i had won
jason congratulations you are our new
fortune fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a bundle of bullion
that's worth 10 grand how you feeling
right now
come on that's incredible please present
your blade to the judges
what fortune fire champion
i don't know how to respond because i
never expected to be here saying that
i don't know
what what do you want from me
all right placements to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do i'm gonna deliver slashes and thrust
on this big carcass
seth you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
all right seth from the snodler to the
trotter every cut with this as you can
see offers a very
deep lacerating cut the only issue is
that your blade did pick up a little bit
of a bend but overall sir with the way
this weapon moves and feels
it will kill
thank you very much good job
all right stephen your turn you ready
sir yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right stephen let's talk about your
saber here
it's a heavy unbalanced sword the minute
you pick up it wants to pull straight
down
it's hard to wield but the weight of
your sword here will definitely bash in
and cut so it will kill
thank you oh bladesmiths a saber is
supposed to be a sturdy weapon so let's
see how yours hold up on our strength
test the ram skull chop
now i'm gonna take each of your sabers
and with no mercy it all bash them into
this ram skull
it's not only gonna test the overall
strength of your knife but the heat
treat on your edge now i don't really
care what your swords do to the skulls i
want to see what the skulls do to your
swords now seth you're up first you're
ready to go swing it good
[Music]
all right seth your edge held up but we
do have a bigger bend in the blade than
we had before your guard
is now
mobile and both of your bolsters came
off as well so this mechanical
connection right in here failed but the
connection between your blade and your
handle is still sturdy
you took some damage but you survived
good job thank you sir
steve after seeing that how you feel
i don't know let's see
[Music]
dave yeah they had a treat
well steve we obviously have a problem
here you got a very coarse grain
structure in here
so i don't know if there was enough
tempering done on this 5160 blade
i mean one strike is all it took and
snapped it right in half so that's
obviously a
problem well steve there's nothing left
to test your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure and can no longer
continue in this competition and for
that reason i have to ask you to please
exit the forge
i'm upset i'm very disappointed that the
blade broke like that
i'm not coming home as a champion but
i'm coming home a whole lot smarter i've
made some friends that i'll have forever
i would do this again no questions asked
well seth this is a competition where
the best blade wins your blade survived
this strength test you are the forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel
surreal right now well good job brother
you're a champion i could not be more
excited about this experience this
competition has been some of the most
fun of my life the money's gonna do some
things for the shop and my wife and my
daughter are gonna go on a real nice
trip
my name is seth boris and i'm the
forging fire champion
welcome to the kill test your sabres
look deadly
to find it out i will take your weapon
deliver some slashes and thrusts on this
ballistic stump
john you're first you ready for this
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
cut its heart out
it's just not right
all right john first up let's talk about
the handle construction it's a little
bit on the big side but i'm able to hold
on to it
now
your edge
it's very sharp
and it is a pleasure to wield because
aside from looking beautiful
it will kill
thank you very much
all right chris your turn are you ready
sir yes sir i sure
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
all right chris let's talk about your
sabre here
first up what i love about it it's got a
sharp edge
every swing i do cuts the one thing here
is that you did pick up a little bit of
a bend right here at this junction it's
warped a little bit
but it pierces and cuts
and most importantly
it will kill
thank you sir
all right bladesmiths for a strength
test i'm going to take your sabers
and i'm going to beat them and stab them
into these field obstacles
now i'm not really concerned about what
your swords do to our obstacles i want
to see the opposite what they do to your
swords john you're first you ready to go
ready to go
hmm
[Music]
nice job john i like the blade
the sword itself overall is on the heavy
side the handle there's a lot there a
lot of extra weight it does help
counterbalance quite a bit though
still got a good edge on it there's some
pretty heavy strikes on there and the
blade bent but came back to true it's
all right tight and straight
good job thank you hey feeling chris
good as it can be sir all right
that right here
no cuts no blood
lucky day
chris your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our strength
test and unfortunately
you cannot continue with testing which
means you cannot be the forest fire
champion
please exit the forge come on forward
path
i did have a small issue when it got to
my heat treat
that's right i didn't want to risk a
second quench because i didn't want to
make it overly brittle i do have some
regret about that decision at this point
of course i would like to be the fortune
fire champion but i am really proud of
myself as a weapons maker and i plan on
getting right back in my forge when i
get home and i'm going to move forward
as ever
well john general patton was known for
being a tough guy and you made a tough
and sharp sword that really honors his
name congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
thank you thank you
how do you feel right now oh yeah
all right man come on over and shake our
hands
good job brother it's a beautiful sword
yeah
i'm the new forage and fire champion you
did a phenomenal job in that hatred
thank you sir i'm proud of what i did
and been a fun deal hey can i get a
forged and fireball buckle now no bell
buckle come on
[Music]
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
find out how lethal your weapons are
according to its historic design i will
take your weapon deliver some killing
slashes and thrust on this or carcass
mitch you're up first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
standing there getting ready to see doug
go at this board with my sword i'm a
little nervous my heart is in my throat
my heart's beating fast i feel like my
legs are shaking and i'm trying to make
them not
all right mitch talk about your sword
here
your edge coupled with the weight that
you have here allows for very deep cuts
with every strike overall sir
you'll kill thank you
all right peyton it's your turn you
ready oh yeah
for this test i'm not too nervous i'm
just excited to see it happen honestly i
get to see this board get cut and a half
hopefully
all right peyton
that was joyous
what i like about this sword it's not
just about the edge or the point it's
the balance in this i can actually use
some velocity
and it cuts deep
overall sir
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
i will be attacking our armored knights
here
now this is not about what your blades
are going to do to that target about
what that target's going to do to your
blades
mitch you're up first you ready for this
yes sir okay
this is definitely more nerve-wracking
than the boar test
if it's going to fail i would say this
would definitely be the test that would
cause the failure i'm just saying to
myself please don't break please don't
break
i think i just peed a little
all right mitch your edge did take some
damage here you can see
the chip
right there and some rolls and your
sword is heavy
you know this is a lot of weight for a
single hand sword more in the range of a
two-handed sword as far as the way it
goes but um she held up
she's in one piece
good job mitch thank you
all right peyton you're up you ready
yeah
one of those i don't know which way my
head's gonna go yeah
so
[Music]
all right peyton it's weighty but the
the weight is all back in my hand so it
doesn't feel
as heavy in the blade this sword has a
much better point of balance than the
other swords your blade did take some
chips and some edge rolling but i think
you your grinds are beautiful the sword
is all
solid you did a good job thank you
all right bladesmith welcome to the
sharpness test the sandbag gauntlet
now to test the sharpness of your weapon
i will slash across these bags now i
like the strength is all about how sharp
your blades are and how well they cut
these bags
mitch europe first you ready yes sir
all right mitch so despite some of the
damage of rolls and chips it wasn't an
issue at all in cutting these bags
it will cut thank you all right peyton
your turns are you ready yes sir
[Music]
all right peyton the handle construction
is smooth but all void enough to where i
wrap my hand around it and i get a very
good grip you'll cut thank you
mitch payton the judge's deliberation is
complete you guys have done fantastic
work on these finale weapons but there
can only be one forged and fire champion
our new forged and fire champion is
payton congratulations you're the force
and fire champion mitch unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut mitch you
brought us a sword that performed well
in all three of our tests so this came
down to the finer points of
craftsmanship as in where to place the
balance point on that blade and the
general weight that balance point being
so far forward made it harder to wield
and harder to control and that's why
we're letting you go i understand
mitch you've been a great competitor
this entire competition but at this time
i have to ask you to please surrender
your blade
obviously disappointed being my first
sword nothing to compare it to i thought
the weight felt good i tried to keep the
six to eight inches balance point that i
was told normally swords carried so
overall happy with what i turned in and
i'm happy for peyton if i had to lose
anyone i just soon lose to him
peyton congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for 10 000
congratulations please present your
sword to the judges
i'm the next fortune fire champion ah
it's just crazy as soon as i heard my
name it's just like a weight just got
pulled off my chest just like
it's over
finally can breathe
all right blane smith welcome to the
kill test
i'm going to take your rapiers and
deliver some killing slashes and thrusts
on this big carcass
for these musketeer swords time to find
out if you're all for one champion or
one for all the runner-ups
jesse europe first you ready for this
let's cut some bacon all right let's do
this
dude
you gotta work out
all right jesse
this edge
is sharp
a rapier cut a big in half
that's very interesting
for every slash the edge lands exactly
where i want it to be okay overall sir
for this test
it will keep
all right ready teddy let's do it let's
do this
[Music]
oh
all right teddy
your edge when you're slashing with the
razor's edge that you have on your blade
it slices easily and deeply on this big
carcass your weapon sir
a little keel
awesome nice
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test little thing i like to
call the wheel of pain
now a rapier needs to be a fast light
flexible weapon we're going to see how
flexible yours are
all right jesse so i've got your blade
strapped into our wheel of pain right
now now i'm going to be flexing it in
both directions i'll be taking it all
the way to that far red peg
holding it for about three seconds
we'll see if it comes back true and then
we're going the other direction all
right
go nuts
that ship sailed
uh
that's back to true dude
are you kidding me okay jesse
first off remarkable but i mean
there's a lot of weight in this blade a
lot of mass
so to have it flex the way it did and
come back virtually to true
this blade
is still straight enough to fight with
which is excellent thank you good job
thank you
teddy you ready for this let's do it
oh very good
holy crap
so teddy you can see where it took the
bends here and here and the initial bend
it actually bent this way and then we
bent it back
and it went the other way so
it leaves some question about the heat
treat
you know how how even it is through the
blade
you know it's just
i worry about that bend
teddy unfortunately a less than perfect
heat treat has led to your rapier taking
a permanent bend now this is going to
affect accuracy when it comes to the use
of the weapon in our sharpness test and
for that reason this is a catastrophic
failure and you cannot continue with
this competition come on forward my
friend
good job brother i'm definitely not
happy no one enjoys having anything they
build not work properly i've had a blast
i've made a few good friends i've been
able to take time and build something i
otherwise wouldn't have built so the
experience has been great
jesse congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and that is the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job brother
i'm on cloud 9. this is probably the
most fun i've ever had doing hard labor
i proved to myself that i'm capable to
do a whole lot more than i thought i
could
[Music]
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
keel test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
weapon deliver some slashes thrust on
this bore carcass frontier first you
ready for this oh yeah let's do it so my
knees will stop shaking all right let's
do this
[Music]
wow
[Music]
all right brad let's talk about your
tizona here the balance of this blade
allows me to really move around with it
and it's a very sharp edge
overall this weapon is one you can move
and bring to combat
and it will kill thank you sir good job
all right thomas your turn you ready
ready as i'll ever be all right let's do
this
ah
[Music]
your tip thrust easy and cuts on the way
out and your edge as you can see same
number of cuts cut all the way through
your first sword it will kill good job
thank you
it's okay to be thrilled kid
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the armored chop to test
the strength and overall construction of
your blades i'll be chopping into our
armored knights here
brent you're up first you ready yes sir
all right brett you've got a couple of
chips and rolls
i don't know that it'll affect the
performance of your blade
it's still sharp
as far as the design of your blade
that's a very slick handle
i like to not be able to do that as
easily
but you did good strong sword one piece
good job thank you
tomas are you ready
i'm ready swing away
all right thomas this has a really fine
edge to it and where it made contact
there are multiple rolls
it's that super fine edge just being
pushed over as it hits that armor
it's an amazingly light sword for as
wide as that is that that's very good
work i mean it's a very broad blade and
it's got a very light feel to it
the handle on this the wrapping on there
gives a good grip it felt really good in
my hand
bottom line it's a strong sword held up
beautifully good job thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test the fish slice
test the edge of your weapon i will
slash away at these salmons
grant here first you ready
[Music]
[Music]
wow
good job
all right let's talk about your sword
here
cut all the way through the fish except
for that it's a sharp edge all the cuts
here are very clean overall sir
it will cut awesome thank you
all right thomas
ready for sushi i am ready let's do this
it's really down to the wire at this
point if my blade doesn't perform as
well as brent's
i'm definitely out of this competition
[Music]
wow good job thank you
all right thomas
every cut was clean all the way through
once again the edge here despite some of
the roles it took earlier have no issues
in performance and quality of cuts
overall sir
it will cut
all right blade smiths the new fortune
fire champion is
brent congratulations you're the new
fortune fire champion thomas
unfortunately a setback in your home
forge
cost you a little bit of detail when it
came to your final product and for that
reason please leave the forge
i'm super disappointed that i didn't win
but i came out here i made a knife with
a drum set i made a sword for the first
time
i'm just so proud of myself for having
taken the risk putting myself outside of
my comfort zone
and
right now i feel like a rock star
rink congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job my friend
oh it feels amazing the adrenaline right
now is just through the friggin roof i
think thank god for this opportunity my
wife for her support
just thank you everyone having trouble
containing everything there's so many
emotions inside right now that i just
want to let them all out
[Applause]
all right bladesmiths your spata swords
look amazing it's time to find out what
kind of lethal damage they can do to do
that i will take your weapon deliver
some killing slashes and blows on this
more than willing ballistics dummy
alex you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
all right alex first up i can really
appreciate the beauty that you have with
your damascus pattern right there it
really stands out
very clean lines the medial ridge you
have on here i can imagine how much work
that takes to get it almost perfectly
straight all the way through to the tip
your tip is sharp enough to penetrate
with the thrust and lacerate on the way
out and most importantly it will kill
thank you good job
all right kevin's your turn so you ready
hell yeah let's do this
alex's uh spot that just destroyed that
uh blow stick's dummy and now i'm
feeling anxious excited
i got the adrenaline going
doesn't have to wrench this
no medial ridge on either side of the
blade it's one of the parameters right
kevin your blade must fall within our
parameters in order to be tested evenly
and fairly with your competitors
your blade does not have a central ridge
that was a parameter that was outlined
before we ever sent you home and for
that reason you cannot be the forged and
fired champion come on my friend
you know it's just a bummer i can't see
a test that's what i really want to see
i want to see how it holds up nice work
on that handle thank you i appreciate it
when i was making it it had the defined
ridge in it just with the sanding and
grinding it just took more of it off but
uh this whole experience has been a
blast congratulations this isn't a loss
i'm coming home with a 10 000 experience
alex you made a sharp and deadly spatha
but not only that you made something
that is detailed and beautiful your
attention to detail has elevated you to
the title of forged and fire champion
congratulations your title comes with a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
this is pretty wild i came here to
challenge myself and put myself through
a super rigorous test and i came out on
top and it feels great it's ten thousand
dollars i'm actually gonna
give it all straight to my parents they
supported me through college as i was
learning blade smithing and they're both
getting ready to retire so
that's all going to them
all right bladesmiths my name is douglas
marquez i will kill the dummies
they are prepared to die
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
rapiers and deliver some thrusts and
slashes on this ballistics dummy
ronnie airport you ready for this
absolutely let's do it
all right ron let's talk about your
rapier here it is a little bit on the
heavier side but it's wieldable and with
a nice swish of a slash it cuts deeply
overall sir your rapier it will kill
good job thank you all right jesse it's
your turn you ready sir yes sir let's
see this i'm extremely nervous i
immediately start questioning my heat
treat and you know just a million things
go through your head
all right jesse let's talk about your
blade here
it's about the same weight
the thrusts penetrate all the way and to
slash well
deep cuts overall sir your blade
will kill thank you sir that's what i
came to hear
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test and yes i am going to
torture your blades ron you're up first
all right
you haven't guessed already it's a flex
test
i'm feeling a little nervous coming into
this test if i left any uneven spots
that could impact the flexibility of
that blade
good job man good job
okay ron
that's a brutal test and he did really
well
if you look at your blade there's the
slightest
of bend in one direction
barely noticeable
the dimensions of the guard are spot-on
and
it's definitely a strong blade nicely
done thank you very much
jesse you ready for this about as
nervous as a long-tailed cat in a room
full of rocking chairs but go ahead
[Music]
first things jesse the guards in the
proper scale
really nicely done issue is you picked
up a bit of a bend
still completely functional usable blade
well done thank you
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
this is all about how sharp your blades
and what it does to this dummy
ron you're up first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
all right ron talk about your edge here
this cut through the clothing and right
into the foam and of course when
thrusting it goes deep overall sir
it will cut thank you
all right jesse it's your turn sir you
ready yes sir let's do this
all right jessie i can still see the
little bend it took at the tip but the
edges are razor sharp on the thrust it
goes deep
it will cut thank you sir
ron jesse you guys have turned in some
really quality blades this is a
difficult decision for us to make and
our forged and fire champion is
ron
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion jesse
please surrender your blade
not being the foraging fire champion is
kind of not what i was looking for but i
lost to a heck of a competitor and a
heck of a blade well done thank you i'm
very proud of the blade i turned in but
if i made this blade again i would have
took a little more time on my heat treat
made sure i had it perfect
being able to start this journey with my
son was pretty awesome and i may not be
the foraging fire champion but i think i
represented my family well
ron congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion you've led your family
to this position and you'll be taking
home a check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother from beginning to end
this has been a great experience
so the hardman house is getting the
forged in fire championship
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
that will take your weapon and deliver
some thrust and slashes on our
dummy from the north
trevor you're up first you ready for
this i'm ready
foreign
all right trevor first up it is so light
just like a needle
your point here allows for a very deep
penetration without any effort overall
sir it will kill
good job all right victor your turn so
you ready
[Music]
all right victor talk about your sword
here it's not very light
overall though it's pointy enough to
thrust
the edge with a weight cut
and
it'll kill
thank you all right gentlemen it's time
for the strength test
to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades just like an
ice pick i'm going to be chipping ice
you up first you ready i'm ready
[Music]
okay trevor you did pick up a slight
bend in your tip
having said that i mean
this thing is so light
which is fantastic thank you
all right victor you are up are you
ready sir ready
[Music]
uh
[Music]
victor
first off blade is
the same shape as when we started out
tip's still there it's fine
your fullers are there but they're not
very deep
and by not having them very deep uh this
this blade is is very heavy uh having
said that it's a strong blade it took no
damage so well done thank you all right
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
the steel can stab and waterbag slice
i will take your weapon i'm going to
test the tip by thrusting into the cans
and i'm going to slash the bag
sorry up first you ready i'm ready
[Music]
all right trevor no issues at all in
stabbing the can and the cut with your
tip on that bag you can see it's
straight cut all the way through overall
sir
it'll cut
thank you
all right victor your turn so you ready
ready
[Music]
all right victor first up in the
stabbing test on one of the thrusts it
pushed the cannon more than penetrated
all the way through but your edge is
sharp on the bag cut cleaning all the
way through more importantly
you'll cut thank you all right gentlemen
i finished my discussion with your
judges and they've made their final
decision our new forged and fire
champion is
trevor congratulations you're the new
force fire champion
victor unfortunately your blade didn't
make the cut by the narrowest of margins
and david baker is going to tell you why
victor the epic combat was supposed to
be a lightning-fast thrusting sword
the weight of your blade led it to be
just a more difficult weapon to use
that's why we're letting you go
victor unfortunately today your blade
doesn't make the cut i'd like to invite
you to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please leave
the forge
this was a great experience and just uh
holding my head high just to know i've
had this opportunity to build this
historical weapon
performed well and i'm proud of it first
thing i do when i go home gets the wife
my son and start forging and get ready
for my next knife show
trevor congratulations you our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother come
on forward my friend
good job i can't believe that i
won forged in fire feeling better than
good the most fun i've had in years with
the ten thousand dollars i i may buy a
new sander
most of it will go to my wife though
[Music]
you